20:18 is shaping up to be a great year
at the movies big franchises are set to
continue with exciting new installments
while highly anticipated original films
promise to take audiences to Wells
they've never even imagined these would
be blockbusters have the potential to
launch a new generation of stars and
showcase incredible performances from
established actors these are just some
of the acting performances you should
look out for in 2018 Chadwick Boseman
Black Panther if you were blown away by
Chadwick Boseman debut as Black Panther
in Captain America Civil War get ready
to see him step up his game even further
in his 2018 solo debut Black Panther
will follow Bozeman's T'Challa
as he returns to Wakanda to take his
rightful place as king it won't all be
smooth sailing for T'Challa though he'll
have to face off against the number of
foes particularly Michael B Jordan Zarek
kill monger a dissident who wants the
throne for himself although we haven't
seen them go head-to-head yet all signs
point to an epic catfight yeah Helen
Mirren Winchester a horror movie
starring Gasca winner Helen Mirren sign
us up for Winchester the house like
ghost belt the film features mirror in a
Sarah Winchester a real-life heiress who
put her entire fortune into her mansion
now known as the Winchester Mystery
House although mirror and has made
horror movies in the past
Winchester's real-life roots and a
characters complex fragile mental state
should add extra weight to her work
seeing an actress of Mirren's caliber
taking on such a multi-faceted role
sounds like a recipe for pure horror the
cast of annihilation Natalie Portman
leads an excellent cast and a sci-fi
thriller annihilation which follows a
group of scientists who head into a
mysterious disaster zone the trailers of
tease some terrifying creatures and ten
scenarios and the film's Erie's science
fiction elements could elevate it beyond
traditional horror fare joining Portman
on her quest to Oscar Isaac Jennifer
Jason Leigh and Gina Rodriguez who post
an Oscar win three Oscar nominations and
five Golden Globe wins between them
that's a heavy weight cast but we'll all
that I think read be enough to get them
past the Nile Asians monsters alive
Jennifer Lawrence red Sparrow Jennifer
Lawrence already has an Oscar and three
more nominations - her name
every role she takes purrs anticipation
for an impressive performance and with
her action thriller red Sparrow Laurence
has taken what could be her most
exciting role to date a ballerina turned
Russian spy as teased in the movies
intense trailer she's part of an elite
group of assassins called the sparrow
Squad who will use whatever it takes to
get the job done although we've mostly
seen smaller worthless pieces of
Lawrence's performance thus far
she looks killer in the role storm read
a wrinkle in time Madeleine L'Engle
philosophical sci-fi Odyssey a wrinkle
in time isn't an easy book to bring to
the big screen and the fact that it's
been so beloved by generations of
readers means there's all the more
pressure to get it right one of the
biggest pieces of the puzzle was the
film's lead MacMurray
luckily director Ava Duvernay found just
the right person for the part in storm
read Duvernay has been very vocal about
how impressed she was with Reed's
performance although we don't know much
about how to vinay will depict Meg's
journey on the big screen Reed seems
poised to cement a rising star status
with an out-of-this-world performance
but the cast of New Mutants 2018 s New
Mutants adds something very different to
the superhero genre horror director Josh
Boone spearheads the film which features
a group of young mutants who find
themselves held in a secret facility
against their will
forcing them to battle the dangers of
their powers and the sins of their past
to try and escape the movie has amassed
an impressive cast of young talent led
by three genre favorites split Sarnia
taylor joy game of thrones' Maisie
Williams and the stranger things is
Charlie Heaton well that's some of the
best young talent around and it should
all add up to a very unique superhero
movie some Hardy venom many people may
have been a bit apprehensive about
sony's planned universe of spider-man
movies that don't feature spider-man but
their fears should have been quieted a
bit when Sam Hardy was announced as a
lead for the first Spidey spin-off of
venom the Oscar nominee is set to play
main character Eddie Brock with the
movie's rumored to offer an r-rated
sci-fi horror take on the morally
ambiguous Marvel villain
party isn't the only talented actor
attached to star envenom Jenny slate
Michelle Williams and Woody Harrelson
are all on board as well along with
Zombieland director Ruben Fleischer
still the performance of the leading man
will make or break the film and Hardees
seems like the man for the job thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]